foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is announcement to take the
place of your primary characters
I want to know that our products are not
meant to treat prevent diagnose or cure
any diseases
available we are honored to hear the
founding fathers of epigenous I'll just
have to load it afterwards so I am to
obtain or maintain I am recording it
here Dr Joel
um
your sound here
we are we're just gonna go with it okay
and hold on one moment
foreign
[Music]
okay recording on Zoom
record to the cloud
oh it's not going to let you I'll record
to my computer and I'll send it to you
thank you recording in progress
got it
all right let's go ahead and get started
hello and welcome everybody so excited
to have you all have come and join us
today
you are plugging into daily with Doc my
name is Becca dukes and I am excited to
be the hostess of this program each and
every Monday through Friday from noon to
one where the program is sponsored by
daily with Doc
Pacific time
I'm sorry Pacific time
Pacific time yes noon to 1 Pacific Time
thank you Dr Wallach for keeping me
straight we don't want anybody to be
confused so if you are noon to one
Pacific time and you're in South Africa
let him in the room
there we go so if you're in South Africa
it's 11 o'clock at night but if you're
on the East Coast it is three o'clock
Pacific or three o'clock Easter
two o'clock Central one o'clock mountain
and noon Pacific time where we air daily
with doc.com you are welcome to join us
live just go to daily with doc.com and
you will find the little form there
where you can request your very own
invitation to the program where you can
also go to daily with Doc zoom.com and
get plugged in with us here live so so
excited to see so many people jumping on
and joining us you guys are fabulous I
love the fact that people are really
getting tuned into wanting to know what
they can do on their own to help
themselves and that's what this program
is all about in providing I do want to
remind everybody that the content of
this program is to provide nutritional
education information only
I do want to remind everybody that this
info this program is to provide
informational
is for informational purposes only it is
not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician and the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
unempowered individual though
we have options and to guide us we are
honored to have one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics
here and if you're not familiar with
epigenetics and you have been told that
you have a genetic condition you're in
the right place for Hope because this
gentleman has proven that there are no
genetic diseases Dr Joel Wallach started
out as a veterinarian he was actually a
student in a Pathology lab and
worked and got his degree in agriculture
and then went on to be a veterinarian
with a doctorate in veterinary medicine
doing some really big projects around
the world where he also acquired three
post-doctorates and pathology
and because of one of his findings
The Cure and the solution I mean the
cause and the Cure
he was fired and he then that opened up
the door for him to be able to teach
nutrition at a naturopathic College
which then he decided hey why not I be
one as myself I love that story Dr
Wallach
so welcome Dr Joel Wallach to daily with
Doc
well thank you so much Beck and of
course
um
the reason I got fired
um this I found the first non-human case
of cystic fibrosis a very terrible birth
defect and I found it in a rhesus monkey
it was going to go into space so it's
NASA they had at the European primate
Center at Emory University in Atlanta
Georgia and I sent around some slides of
the lungs in the liver and tissues and
so forth but I didn't tell them the
slides were from a monkey I just said I
think this is physical Rose is the way
to think and all these medical schools
read classic example and I had it on
their letterheads and of course the
people at Yorkies were excited and said
well yeah you know at the very least
we've got a a
laboratory animal here now okay so we
can study City barrosis and then I got
permission to do tests on the other 24
baby monkeys out there there's all
different mothers and fathers and they
all had cystic fibrosis because the
um people who are in charge of the diets
of the monkeys took them all off of the
pellets
because they're plucking their hair and
all that kind of stuff they said well
have too much time they just eat the
pellets and they're not hungry so they
took away their pellets with all the
items and minerals in it and just gave
them carrots and
um raisins and things like that so
they're busy all day eating vegetables
and fruit and so forth
and so that's why the babies had
cerebrosis and then the next one oh they
all had cyberosis and that's when I said
it's not a genetic thing and I showed it
to him because I was going to give a
talk at a federal meeting and they fired
me
that's when I went back to school and
became taught the sharp version as I
taught nutrition also took courses I got
credit for some of my Veterinary courses
um you know like biochemistry and that
kind of stuff
and um
let's see here before that
um when I was as you say I was working
my way through veterinary school by
working in the Pathology Department it
was Christmas of
1963 a year before I graduated
veterinary school and all the professors
were gone and I'm working in the
Pathology Department because you know
needed money to pay for tuition and
books and so forth
and
the um this is a farmer came by and he
dropped off 50 dead Lambs I said oh my
gosh what happened he says well
um
I yesterday I had 500 Lambs
and um we're gonna share them just after
Christmas
because it was six months old and then
after New Year's we're gonna take them
you know to slaughter
and he said they're all happy yesterday
you know following the wagon and jumping
and out of the feed bunks as we're
putting feet in there for them and this
morning they were all dead 500 were dead
and turns out that the neighboring Farms
have been using high levels of nitrates
as fertilizers was drained into their
water supply and they were drinking
um nitrate contaminated drinking water
for six months their thyroids were dead
and the night they all died the
temperature dropped down to 16 and they
all died of hypothermia because their
thyroids couldn't help them maintain
their body temperature
so I wrote it all up got a published in
a minority journal and
that that started the whole thing
very very excited and so
um I I pay attention to a lot of details
and most people don't
okay so that's why I'm able to figure
things out of course we have a 75-year
right now that's epigenetics that's a
summary of my thesis which is in the
Smithsonian Institute on those 20 000
autopsies and my thesis okay sells for
twenty five thousand dollars each but
still in the um
let's see if it's still in the package
and not unwrapped yet and so forth and
you can go
on Siri and ask Siri are there any of my
books diseases of exotic animals
available for sale
and you can find them all beat up the
dog is peed on them and all that kind of
stuff and a lot of writing in the
margins and dog-eared and you can get
them for fifteen hundred three thousand
five thousand eight thousand dollars and
it's still too much for a lot of people
so we came up with a summary of all that
information and it's called epigenetics
the death of the genk Theory Z
transmission and that one sells for 25
bucks
and so I got another secret coming out
here I'll tell you in a couple of days
maybe next week because we're we got
another thing happening here in that
subject
um
but anyway
um this just came out about a month ago
the Wallach Revolution this is actually
the uh the second okay this is the
second printing uh it was put together
by a committee
of
medical doctors phds and attorneys who
didn't want to be named so they just
called themselves the committee for good
health or something like that and that
was the first one and um it was just a
beautiful thing and so we added two
years later we added a whole lot of
information to it and this version
covers 75 years of very famous people
like uh Danny Glover
um Pat Boone
um Andy young Theo Ratliff
um let's see here also
um Evander Holyfield many many famous
people in in health issues and sports
and so forth that riding their parts
their stories in here okay
so it's just it's a wonderful thing
we're very proud of that and that's
available now
let's see here okay the walk Revolution
and there's two stories I want to jump
into now which are very very current
one of which
um goes back a couple of weeks ago now
uh Bruce Willis very famous
um actor okay Bruce Willis die hard one
of my favorite movies and TV series a
detective okay Bruce Willis he developed
FTD
frontal temporal dementia it's kind of
an Alzheimer's disease and also almost
like Ms in certain parts of the brain
and um I guarantee you is because he was
told to go into cholesterol restricted
diet he may even been given a
prescription of statin drugs lower
cholesterol because you may have had
high blood pressure or something like
that
and it turns out
um let's see here because of all this
okay
um it affected the white matter in his
brain the myelin in his brain okay and
he has Aphasia he can't speak well he
can't read anymore and he can't remember
anything he can't solve simple problems
okay and
um this is one of those things where let
me get my light here this is one of
those things where oh he also has
vertigo balance problems Parkinson's
disease
all of which or white matter
loss okay in the brain and so what I
want to do for Bruce Willis is everybody
needs to write him a letter or send him
an email we want him to get off all the
bad foods no fried foods no process
means no oils no glutens no wheat and
brown oats no sugar no carbonate or
drinks even the diet one's got to go and
also carbonate water no alkaline water
and then I wanted him to take two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
two how the brain and heart pasture a
month twice a day two bottles of MSM so
you can take three at breakfast lunch or
dinner they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
Layman's tendons and extra tissue disc
retina vertebrae bone makes on himself
including the skull
and then I want them to have the I-26 he
needed to take one of those with each
meal or three Rebecca likes to take them
all at one time so three at lunchtime
okay they're chewable
um I wouldn't say they're super sugary
or anything like that but they're
Pleasant you know they're not bitter or
anything like that okay so three of the
chewable
um I-26 and then three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks
and then it wouldn't hurt to throw in
the synaptives two bottles a month of
the synaptic so we can take three twice
a day so as rain can talk and brain
cells can talk to each other and also he
also needs
um let's see here memory effects through
those twice today I believe we can bring
him back okay then the other one is a
little bit different story but it also
affected the brain Tom Sizemore many
people recognize that name
let's see here oh Bruce Willis is 67
years old and he's right spiraling
downwards okay
Tom Sizemore last Thursday a couple of
days ago
um died at 61. two days ago okay
after having a ruptured aneurysm in the
brain when they did an MRI in his brain
he said oh this is a mess in there
because of the big artery and the the
blood squirting tore up the brain so
he's not gonna live he died three days
later but he was a very famous actor he
made 200 movies
Saving Private Ryan
Black Hawk Down
you can see here born on the fourth of
July
Pearl Harbor he was kind of a star on
the Twin Peaks TV series in 200 movies
okay and again
um the ruptured aneurysm is caused by a
deficiency of a single nutrient
so these two guys are suffering from all
those these brain issues from
nutritional deficiencies I guarantee
their doctors were telling them what to
do what to eat what not to eat and um
that sort of stuff and you know they
felt confident because their doctor was
saying it and but they chose poorly and
Bruce Willis is still alive and we hope
that his family gives
this information
um because many people are hearing it
and I hope everybody emails them and
have them contact us
so we can save Bruce Willis so
um with all that said Okay I want
everybody to really really think about
this
you can eat well but see plants don't
make minerals plants can make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids which are
all carbon compounds but plants do not
make minerals nutritional minerals occur
in a uniform blanket around the crust of
the earth no they occur in veins like
gold and silver
okay and
it used to be the most fertile land was
bottomland that's what was so expensive
and families would never somebody would
die who in their family would have
bottom line they wouldn't put it on sale
they kept track of it for themselves
okay bottomland that's because it was
for fluttery spring when the flood water
was rested it left a silt that the flood
waters had brought down from the
mountains the farmers would plowed in
and renew the soil's mineral content
from the previous year when all of the
crops suck the minerals out of the soil
okay and so really in addition to the
book
the wall of Revolution and epigenetics I
also want to get a hold of the book it's
all in your head
there's 37 different diseases you can
get you have obviously a process of the
skull
okay there you go and the top skull is a
quarter managed thick
uh you have to move that a little bit to
your right
there you go no to your right
it's center.iscreen doc go ahead okay
but your screen is covered by everybody
else
okay
so and then of course the bottom skull
is an inch and a half two inches thick
that's the one that has the
osteoporosis of the skull and all these
things have enormous impact on the
Health and Longevity of the of the
individual
and so we're so glad that people are
jumping in and saying hey this makes
sense
and so we can help people add 25 to 50
healthful years think of that 25 to 50
Health years your life get rid of a lot
of unnecessary misery increase the
quality of your life I mean come on and
so
um when you get this information
it's one of those things where
somebody pays the price
all right and it's one of those things
where
um the patient pays the price when
they're getting this information
so let's see here
um I do want to remind everybody
that um I think I I gotta do I have five
or ten more minutes
Becca you're the boss doc okay
but we do have questions so let's leave
time for questions okay are we ready for
questions or
yeah we have questions up ready
okay well let's go for questions
okay well we have our lovely co-host
with a question here who is bringing it
from our chat so Marilyn go ahead and
unmute yourself first
okay hi everyone
I have a Woman by the name of Linds
that's saying good afternoon I have a
customer that has lymph node cancer it's
currently taking chemo
he had stomach cancer several years ago
he's a male height five nine weight 200
approximately 30 to 40 years old and he
has nauseous he's nauseous tired and
depressed
well I can see why two different cancers
okay so anyway he needs to get rid of
all the bad stuff he needs to get a hold
of my book doctor always cooking without
the bad food is 300 pages of safe
recipes and safe cooking methods okay
then he needs to get on two of our
healthy brain and heart packs a month to
photos everything uh twice a day he
needs two bottles a month of our MSM so
I can take three brackets straight lunch
and dinner they're going to support and
promote means repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
including the bone marrow or the white
blood cells and antibodies are made
which are going to go kill and eat the
cancer cells okay very important
now let's see here
then he also needs to be taking the
collagen peptides I'll scuba that with
his morning drink a scuba that was
evening drinking it's collagen from
let's see here fish poultry sheep and
beef
and also helps support the immune system
and then uh let's see here
[Music]
um
I
also one him nice you know to again get
a hold of that book so he can know what
bad foods to avoid including carbonated
water
um gluten no wheat butter and oats there
are no such things as safe wheat Brown
knows my doctor says eat more whole
grains well your doctor's giving you
misinformation
gluten will kill you okay and it
destroys a little villain in your
intestines they cannot absorb nutrition
you lose 90 of your absorptive surface
you cannot have buckwheat buckwheat
doesn't have any gluten in it says it
right on the label no gluten but it does
have fago Pyrenees f-a-g will cave
Pyrenees which are worse than gluten so
you have to stay away from all the bad
stuff and take these nutrients support
your immune system
you can add many many Health years of
your life
herbs that
that like oat straw
does it actually have oats in it
no you cannot have the grain or the
straw and you cannot have anything with
oats
or barley or Rye or wheat
you cannot have the breakfast a champion
you cannot have oatmeal you cannot have
um pancakes or waffles made from those
things
you cannot have oatmeal porridge
unless you want to kill yourself 25
years early yeah I was just always
running with herbs because I have cat's
claw and I'm like does that have cat's
claw actually in it so that's why I
asked well if it says it has cancer claw
it's got to have cats claw in there okay
cat's Claw is an herb not the actual
claw thank you
from the herbalist side of me
[Laughter]
okay
thank you great question though Marilyn
thank you so much for for bringing that
question now Dr Wallach
um we have oh goodness we probably have
over a hundred questions that have been
emailed in so I'm going to go ahead and
get a couple
of those here as well
and Paul has a question he says
I am five foot seven
230 pounds 53 years old
I have high blood pressure
high cholesterol along with neck back
knee foot shoulder pain and carpal
tunnel and tinnitus in the ears please
help
okay if you have to Madison ears Paul
you have osteoporosis in the skull you
need to get a hold of the book and the
CD set it's all in your head
um and then at 230 pounds you need to
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat butter and oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbon or drinks
even the diet ones need to go and also
the carbonated water needs to go uh at
230 pounds you need two healthy brain
and hard packs a month to follow
something twice a day you need
um
two bottles a month of the MSM so you
can take three of breakfast for dinner
they're going to help rebuild part
leaves ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the vertebrate bone
microphone itself
you need for the high blood pressure I
would also have you take oh don't forget
the collagen peptides to scuba that with
your morning drinks or their evening
drink those two canisters months
um have a pressure you want to get two
bottles a month of our ultimate daily
classic tablets take three at breakfast
three dinner time do not cold turkey off
your medication but as your blood
pressure begins to drop you can slowly
reduce medication based on the numbers
and then because you have
tinnitus in the ears that's telling me
that your skull is squeezing the
auditory branch of the eighth cranial
nerve that's very classic symptom and I
would like to know how many times this
guy gets up at night to urinate once
three times five times ten times okay
um
they've got all these joint problems
because when you have osteoporosis of
the skull you have osteoporosis in every
joint of your body not just your skull
okay when you have osteoporosis in every
joint in your body you have osteoporosis
in your skull not just your joints and
your body okay we spend on arthritis
and osteoporosis each here in America
just to treat the symptoms three
trillion dollars a year three trillion
dollars a year
okay that's because doctors get to treat
the patients for
10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 100 years
whereas they train for cancer they might
treat them for three or six months and
they live or die
okay so we're spending a lot of money on
treating the symptoms of arthritis and
osteoporosis because it is a what should
I say it is a live stream of the
American Medical system
um
but don't forget all those
MSM don't forget the collagen peptides
um and depending on where they live they
might want to get vitamin D3 so they can
absorb the nutrients put them in the
right place
and then call US every couple of weeks
uh the cholesterol issue
I want to know what elevated cholesterol
means okay
um and so
uh cholesterol
if it's the good cholesterol okay makes
up 25 of your brain weight and 25
percent of your spinal cord weight
and it actually prevents
Alzheimer's disease prevents
Parkinson's disease prevents Ms and
Guillain-Barre syndrome and all that
kind of stuff prevents
um
demyelization myelin is the white matter
of the brain is spinal cord it's an
essential nutrient
and I believe this is what messed up
um
you know our our hero
um Bruce Willis Bruce Willis yeah Bruce
Willis uh I I I just have to guess that
the doctors had him on a cholesterol
restricted diet because it may have had
high blood pressure medicine blocked
arteries they put him on cholesterol
lowering medication okay and he's paying
the price okay so I hope his family gets
this information because I believe we
can save Bruce Willis
um
and usually I say give me 90 days but he
will see benefit long before 90 days but
always give me 90 days especially when
the brain is involved
because we're gonna go slow and steady
and make sure everything is right so I I
just hope to hear from the Bruce Willis
family
yes that would be nice
I want them to to end his career yet so
I have another question in coming in
from Patty and Alan is 62 year old male
five foot eleven
215 pounds
has high blood pressure and is on
medications for it high PSA of seven
regarding the posture prostate
it has acid reflux which he takes the
medication for seasonal allergies which
it takes enough medication for
um
and they had just learned about the bad
foods so they're working on the bad
foods and they want to know what
youngevity products that you have come
up with would you recommend for Alan Dr
Wallach okay well he needs to get rid of
all the bad foods that's why we have the
book psychological cooking without the
bad foods
300 pages of safe
recipes and safe cooking methods and
then
um
I need to get the
um let's see here too healthy branded
heart packs for months it's one per 100
pounds of body weight so two healthy
brain and hard crash a month the photos
are sitting twice a day two miles a
month of the MSM so he can take three at
breakfast lunch free dinner time so he
can absorb all the nutrients necessary
to help rebuild cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and connective tissue and
all that kind of stuff is bones and
joints and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue including those
arteries I'm going to watch that
and then
um because he has a habit pressure he
needs two bottles a month or ultimate
daily classic tablets three of those
twice a day if he's on medication do not
cold turkey off of it but as the as the
blood pressure begins to drop you can
still reduce medication based on the
numbers the prostate we do have
prostitfx
and he can take three of those twice a
day if he's not been diagnosed with
prostate cancer if it's just an enormous
prostate he's going to have the process
FX take three twice a day and let's see
here
um
[Music]
but at the time I wrote down something
like here like reflex something
allergies so seasonal allergies okay we
have that seasonal immune pack which I
absolutely love Dr Wallach okay well go
for the acetylene pack and um
uh don't forget the three eggs twice
today three eggs twice a day uh soft
boiled soft salt and scramble butter not
Hardball not fried
and I think that's where oh don't forget
the rebound or sword string for energy a
rebound it would be perfect for this guy
again we have three forms we have sticks
there's 30 sticks in a box there's 100
nutrients in there and he's thick
um we have the canister there's 36
servings there in the powder and it's um
again 36 servings it has 100 nutrients
and we do have the 12 ounce cans or 12
cans in a case but the cans do have
carbonation in them
so what I recommend is people to pump
the top Stone two of them before they go
to bed at night and put them in the
refrigerator they'll be flat in the
morning all the bubbly's gone I drink
one with breakfast and one in the
afternoon and people say well if the
carbonation is bad why don't you take it
out of there that's because all these
kids that are drinking Red Bull and all
these other energy drinks love the
carbonation and we didn't have the
carbonation they wouldn't even look okay
at us okay so we want to educate them on
what to do
Red Bull only has one mineral magnesium
we have 75 minerals by my number 75
minerals are healthier than one mineral
okay
and you can ask Bruce Lee how that one
mineral magnesium worked for him he died
at 32
of a heart attack okay because he's only
taking one middle he believes he could
get everything else he needed from just
eating well he that didn't work out
because he died of 32 of a heart attack
and he was considered the fitness Guru
by every country in the world
during the 1960s
so
I think we're ready for another one
all right well Dr Wallach I just wanted
to talk about the rebound for just a few
minutes
um because you know the cans are great
if you're just going to be taking it
popping it put it in the refrigerator
let it go flat and then drink it but for
those that are active and have an active
lifestyle and need to take it with them
I love the sticks like what Dr Wallach
is holding up right there that is the
powder you just take one of those 16
ounce water bottles take a little bit
off the top sip it because you need
water anyways pour it in there shake it
up and you're good to go
so and for those of us who are not
always out on the go the canister is my
favorite
and it has the least amount of sugar of
all three of them if you're concerned
about sugar so
great pick me up great way to get your
minerals
and so much more Dr Wallach it's not a
replacement for the 90 essential
nutrients I just want to make sure
everybody knows that yeah and because
there's things missing in there that you
get into 90 cents nutrients that's why I
get a ticket with the 90 essential
nutrients but anyway
um you're going to get 100 nutrients
twice a day if you take two doses of
um the rebound because there's 75
minerals and 25 bonds amino acids if you
take the hell the brain and heart pack
or the Healthy Start pack you're going
to get 100 nutrients so you're going to
get 100 nutrients four times a day if
you're doing this correctly
and so
go ahead oh you say this can add 25 to
50 healthful years to your life this is
not difficult you pay attention to high
quality oil in your car you don't just
put dirt from Texas in there oh come on
there's bound to be some oil in that
dirt from Texas because it's dirt from
Texas nobody would do that to their car
that's what you're doing to yourself
when you say just like Bruce Lee did oh
I'm going to just eat well and get
everything I need because my doctor said
so
well I love the high octane performance
so what I have and I don't have
everything for the brain and heart pack
in my little cart here
um
but the Beyond Tangy Tangerine
okay this says the majority of your
vitamins your minerals it has amino
acids it has a whole food blend
and as I'm looking at this
it's got the 90 essential nutrients it's
gluten free it's sugar-free with natural
and non-GMO ingredients
and Dr Wallach for those that are
concerned about orac
it has 8 000 total orac wow per serving
so that's that's one
of the products in the healthy body pack
then we have the osteofx
this is the Beyond osteoflex it's a
powder it has your
connective tissue in your bones the
things that's needed to make strong bone
marrow right Dr Wallach that's correct
and that includes all the cofactors
folks we need more than just calcium we
need more than just
easy
um we need more manganese phosphorus
zinc copper MSM the trace minerals so
you're getting a few more trace minerals
here glucosamine Boron and strontium
that pulls it deep into the bones I mean
if you're looking for a bone and joint
formula
this is top of the line
and I love it because it's affordable Dr
Wallach
and then
EFA plus ultimate EFA plus this has your
Omega 3 6 and 9 nice ratio so that
you're making sure that you get the 90
essential nutrients with these three
which have your 60 minerals 12.
is it 12 vitamins or 12 amino acids
I think it's a 12 test 12 vitamins
okay 12 vitamins and 16 amino acids plus
your three EFA so I just wanted to do a
little rundown of what is the 90
essential nutrients now for the braided
heart pack we add another essential
fatty acid because they are so important
I mean Dr Wallach you've talked about
the essential fatty acids and how
they're important for brain skin heart
eyes preventing blood clots preventing
blood clots their Natures blood cleaner
folks
think about that Nature's blood cleaner
they're pretty spectacular and you do
not want to miss them thinking oh that's
just fish oil no no no no no no there's
so much to the essential fatty acids
that are body requires if we want to
thrive
and then the ultimate selenium
with all the cofactors
that helps to
keep our vessels strong
so I love that Dr Weller but I wanted to
just go over that real quick
um let's go to next hand that is up and
Carmen go ahead and unmute yourself
and folks if you are on live with us we
do have that chat box open make sure
that you have it open as well our
co-hosts are putting information in that
chat that will help you find the
products that Dr Wallach is mentioning
by spelling them out for you and if you
have questions we do try to get to the
questions that are in the chat box also
but if you want to raise your hand then
go ahead and raise your hand and come on
live with us so Carmen
hi I'm in the hospital here with my mom
and so she's on this they put her back
on a feeding
liquid stuff because the PEC tube has
something wrong with it and I wanted to
know can I ask the doctor when he looks
at her tomorrow morning if he can just
keep her on the feeding with the liquid
as opposed to the peck tubes they can
take that out of her stomach since it's
having issues or is that not able to do
that and um this is America you're
you're able to ask them any question you
want
okay and then she had double pneumonia
and I've been putting essential oils on
her because I can't put anything in her
mouth
um and she went from double pneumonia to
regular plain old pneumonia in one day
so I know they're working and I just
wanted to know if you think it's
possible she can't she's having
difficulty swallowing there's a thing
that opens up or something my sister's
trying to explain to me when you swallow
it goes in one side when you breathe it
goes away that's a lot of stuff here at
town she has difficulty doing that so
that's why they put the PEC tube in her
because she's her mom 94 should be 95 in
a week or two yeah the odds are she has
as she approaches the skull squeezing
the ninth cranial nerve the
glossopharyngeal nerve which causes that
part of the digestive system to not be
able to swallow okay changes okay so it
knocks off The Voice okay so if I put
the minerals on her will that help her
to swallow better because we're waiting
for them tomorrow the minerals should
come the longevity stuff tomorrow yeah
you can rub the minerals on her and once
you get a whole there's a DVD and a CD
set called Praise the Lord and Pastor
90. it's a story about
um Pastor Mike Freeman who was in a coma
for six months and the doctor said oh
he's only got hours or days at the most
to live here so um Linda Taylor one of
our great Distributors from up there in
in Baltimore Maryland and and Pastor
Mike's wife rubbed their plant minerals
you know a half a teas cup a tea cup on
his chest and his belly and his back
between his shoulder blades and lower
back three times a day for three days he
wakes up
he wakes up he shaves he goes back to
work at the church at the TV studio in
the radio studio and tells the story to
the world for the whole day and
fortunately he recovered uh all that and
I already recorded it okay and so we
made this tool out of it you can get the
tool by going to the
www.drjwalek.com
www.drjwalk.com get a hold of that tool
okay
um let's see here is called Praise the
Lord and pass the 90. praise the Lord
and pass the Night by just rubbing those
minerals on him he came out of a death
spiral the doctor said he only had hours
or days to live at the most
okay and they got her on antibiotics
for eight hour drip and um so antibodies
can be useful you know if somebody her
age is in a serious problem
um especially in a hospital uh you want
antibiotics because
deserts are coming from one room so
somebody's got covet or pneumonia okay
all right I just wanted to check with
you thank you God bless you thank you
God bless you let us know how Mom doing
okay thank you
okay all right thank you so much Carmen
Dr Wallach
have you ever used a mouse
I'm sure you're supposed to work have
you ever played with a mouse
not like a
yeah
I'm not talking about the furry and
animals I'm talking about these things
don't always work when you want them to
oh
but let's go ahead and go to Michael and
just a reminder everybody if somebody
shared this program with you get back
with them make sure that
you tell them thank you thank you for
sharing this information and ask them
how they get their products because
there's a chance that they have a
special way to get their products if
there's no one to thank you are welcome
to go to daily with doc.com there you
will find all of the replays from our
past programming you will also find Dr
wallach's Good Foods bad foods list
you'll find a way that you can sign up
for our newsletter and also you will
find a store that has all of the
products that Dr Wallach is mentioning
on today's program and every program
Michael
go ahead and unmute yourself
hello Michael
can you unmute
all right we're gonna go ahead and go do
Marilyn who has another question Dr
Wallach from the chat Marilyn okay I'm
not sure Rebecca or Dr 12th if you can
answer this but do you know the
difference between our seasonal immune
pack this was a question in the chat
versus the immune 911 I don't have the
specific ingredients
I know the answer to that mu911 is just
one products that has stuff that helps
to build the immune system the seasonal
immune pack actually has five different
tablets that helps to support the immune
system in a much bigger way but it also
gives that added little stuff that helps
with allergies through nutrition and
also some herbal synergist Synergy so
that is the difference between immune
9-1-1 fantastic that was from Corey
thank you thank you Corey
all right Michael are you able to unmute
yet
all right we're gonna go to the next
question Dr Wallach and in an email
we have a Michael also that is writing
in different last name he says I am 59
years old 330 pounds with hypothyroidism
fatty liver gluten sensitivity so
there's a chance he's already avoiding
it
I led an aluminum bloating
he says don't have a BM every day
he has dry skin high estrogen high
testosterone and the gallbladder has
been removed Dr Wallach so what would
you recommend for Michael he doesn't
mention you know how many times he gets
up to go the restroom but he has quite a
bit of stuff going on here yeah okay
well he needs to get rid of all the bad
foods and again that book uh Dr wants
cooking about the bad foods 300 pages of
safe recipes and safe cooking methods Dr
Walsh cooking without the bad foods
that's very important to absorb things
and utilize them and then the 330 pounds
ideally he would have three healthy
brain and heart pasture month the photos
everything three times a day if finances
are an issue don't go below two okay
then he needs a minimum of two vowels a
month of the MSM because I wanted to
have three at breakfast three lunch
three dinner time okay and that's going
to help him rebuild cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue and all that kind of stuff I want
them to have our collagen peptides you
can take a scoop of that with his
morning drink a scoop of that with his
lunch drink and scuba that was his
evening drink so he'll need two
canisters a month for that okay and so
it helps again with everything including
the immune system which is your bone
marrow so you can make white blood cells
to go out there and kill the bad guys
and so forth and then I also because
he's he has his gallbladder taken out
I wanted to have our gallbladder in a
bottle it's called our ultimate enzymes
it does have bile in it to replace what
you're not getting because the doctors
took the gallbladder out I wanted to
have uh say two or three of those say 10
minutes before each meal
um okay with a couple ounces of water
and he'll be able to absorb the fat cell
vitamins essential fatty acids and all
that kind of stuff all the good stuff
all right and then I want him also to
take one meal a day our keto Shake one
meal a day our keto Shake uh comes in
chocolate and strawberry it's not to be
added to a meal it's a meal replacer it
doesn't have to be the same meal every
day but he can lose a half a pound of
two pounds a day and at five let's see
here his height I uh
um I think he was five eleven doc five
eleven okay almost six foot yeah he
should weigh about 200 pounds so he's
about 130 pounds overweight
and um this is
um
very easy to do okay just take that one
meal again it's not to be added to a
meal it's a meal replacer it doesn't
have to be the same meal every day and
again it comes in chocolate or
strawberry so you can kind of you know
have the both of them so you so you're
not getting bored with one flavor all
the time
and so um he'll lose a half pound two
pounds a day and because he has a
thyroid issue in addition I want him to
have two bowels a month of our Ocean's
gold so he could take three breakfasts
or dinner time only have two bottles a
month or a few quite Z which is seaweed
from another ocean so he can take the
three of those twice a day I do that I
only weigh 142 and I take three of each
twice a day and then also he needs the Z
radical the Z radical he needs a couple
of ounces twice a day even three times a
day be okay for him he's a big guy okay
and then don't forget the rebounder
sports drink this guy
um the reason why he's so heavy he's
really really
I'm seriously deficient in nutrients
particularly minerals and that's why he
eats all the time that's why he's so big
as soon as he starts doing everything
correctly he'll slowly lose about a half
a pound of two pounds a day but don't
forget the rebound or sports drink again
we talked about that a little earlier we
have the sticks there's 36 in a box we
have the canister there's 36 servings in
the canister we do have
the 12 ounce cans uh 12 in a case the
cans do have carbonation in them so I
like to pop the tops on them uh two of
them before I go to bed at night put
them in the refrigerator so that they're
flattened all the bubbly's gone by
morning
um and again we keep those because the
kids want to order the ones with the
carbonation in them but then we educate
them to get off the carbonation now once
they start with us okay and so we don't
just leave them to do the carbonation
until they die okay we make sure that
they know that they want to really
really work on getting rid of the
carbonation
but anyway
um that that covers um this fella
you mentioned hypothyroidism and I know
that the thyroid people oh yeah I said
Ocean's gold and I said Z and Z radical
all three of those will support the
thyroid
now the thyroid needs iodine right
whether it's hyper hypo or just having a
thyroid with no concerns
okay the thyroid gland requires all 90
essential nutrients
it uses uses iodine to make the hormone
and I don't like to you know tell people
that over the year because they just run
to the store and buy iodine and then
they wonder why
we have something called ultimate iodine
Dr Wallach
and it includes vitamin B12 iodine zinc
selenium and copper that all work
together to help support the the
the thyroid and that's something that I
added when during my weight loss journey
is I added three sprays of this twice a
day
whenever I hit plateaus when I hit a
plateau is when I started adding this
and it's just little sprays right under
the tongue and
boy I had more energy how much weight
how much weight did you lose in your
journey
I'm down 105 pounds wow lost 105 pounds
that's beautiful no I didn't lose it huh
yeah I didn't lose it I said goodbye
see ya
because I'm not gonna find it back so
and that's majority of that 100 pounds
Dr Wallach has been
um for the last three years so
yeah
I'm doing good well thank you
yes thank you so let's go to my friend
Bobby
go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with daily with Doc
you know Rebecca Dukes my friend and Dr
Wallach have a male 62 years old
um 6-1 262 pounds
and having problems with um gout high
blood pressure
constipation and eating junk food
I'm sure eating what
junk food oh
all right well again people who eat junk
food are usually
mentally deficient and so they're
craving
snacks all the time
they're just they might eat
five six seven eight ten meals a day
that's why they gained so much weight
and once you start taking the 90
essential nutrients a lot of that
craving goes away and it's easy to lose
the way when you throw in the a keto
Shake he needs one keto shake a day
okay it could be the chocolate or the
strawberry or should we rotate them
around so you don't get bored with one
flavor
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
doctor while he's cooking without the
bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes and
safe cooking methods then uh absolutely
no
let's see here no wheat butter rare oats
no buckwheat you can get rid of the
gluten and the fago Pyrenees absolutely
no fried foods no processed Meats with
nitrates and nitrites okay we're talking
about ham bacon bologna salami hot dogs
pastrami pepperoni jerky corned beef
spam all that stuff's got to go
and then
um
and gout is problems you know in your
joints okay and so again
um we do have
the the things we told
this guy to take okay again it's the
um
yeah he needs the shake okay the keto
Shake
um One A Day don't go to any more than
that because then you're getting into
nutritional trouble so you need just one
keto shake it it's not to add to a meal
it's a meal replacer
and then again the ultimate daily
classic tapestry those twice a day or
even three three times a day to help get
rid of the hybrid pressure and don't
cold turkey off the medication but as
the blood pressure drops you can reduce
the medication
um let's see here so I think we're we're
covering things and he wants pain
medication for the gout he can use our
CM cream topically on the joints and
it'll give them very very good pain
relief for you know um
um you know anywhere from
two to five hours okay kind of thing
but these sorts of things we see people
all the time athletes military personnel
people who do factory work
and
um
gout usually runs along with thyroid
problems okay so it wouldn't hurt
to you know take the
um
oceans gold three of those twice a day
two thousand months and a few quite Z
take through those twice a day and then
the Z radical
um you want to take
um a couple of ounces of that
with um breakfast lunch and dinner the Z
radical it's also going to help with
these issues
all right thank you so much Dr Wally can
we have time for one more quick question
and Ruth Ellen do you have a question
for Dr Wallach please unmute yourself I
do thank you so much good afternoon
everyone okay so I have a question from
Facebook
um it is from Sharla I hope I'm
pronouncing that right it's c-h-a-r-l-a
um says good afternoon I have a client
who's female 120 pounds five foot six
following your protocol of food no
gluten oats or oats um also sticking to
the bad foods list because I did ask
um
is on a healthy brain and hard pack and
is wondering how long before ear ringing
dry skin stressed tummy teeth and teeth
aching
will start to reduce and go away she is
also taking I gotta scroll down sorry uh
collagen synaptive de-stress glucogel
plant Drive minerals and sweet ease
she's been on the product since October
of 22.
and I do know that
um it does depend on the damage to the
small intestines repairing itself for
um
absorption is uh better yeah and so she
should be you know after
three to six months so she should be
um
healing or small intestines but she's
got to watch out for cross-contamination
in the household everybody in the
household including the dog and the rat
and the parrot and spouse and kids
mother-in-law everybody's got to be
gluten-free she can't be the only one
gluten-free in the household because
it'll be cross-contamination in the
laundry the dryer food preparation
services
um even the car when people are eating
crackers and cookies and things like
that
um and again uh these
um
with these big long sticks with salt all
over them
pretzels yeah pretzel sticks yeah okay
um so they're gluten you go to a
restaurant every you know even if
they're bringing you something that's
gluten free guess what they're they're
making it on a surface that has gluten
on it I like Jimmy Carter I I you know I
don't want to talk about his politics
but
um he's 98 years old doesn't have any
issues he's been eating
grits his whole life for breakfast lunch
and dinner which is just a cornmeal
no wheat by the rare oats uh he's been
uh let's see here also for breakfast he
has three eggs every morning
he has Dairy he has milk and cheese and
butter with every meal
everything the doctors say don't do he's
done and he's 98.
okay they want to put him in hospice
because he's 98 and says if you have a
heart attack or something we can help if
you're in hospice we can save you okay
but if you know it's going to take him a
half hour to get an ambulance out there
and blah blah he'll die before you get
to the hospital he says no thank you
I'll just stick it out at home I'm doing
pretty good right now because he's still
fishing and you know playing golf and
all that kind of stuff at 98. and so and
also for lunch he has
um
uh let's see here he has Dr Holly I hate
to interrupt you Dr Wallach but you've
got to go
that's true thank you thank you thank
you you can finish it up
yeah well thank you everybody for
joining us here
bye doc
on daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and if I could have my other co-host up
with me so we have the wonderful Ruth
Ellen Sanchez she she's had a lot of
stretching and growth over this last
month and a half or so
um and making sure that we learn how to
do this live streaming stuff
um it's more than just going live on
Facebook whenever you are doing a zoom
doing a large broadcast and streaming to
multiple different platforms so if you
are a rumble user go to critical Health
news and follower
Rumble Channel if you're on YouTube
again critical Health news
follow us and if you are on Facebook
it's just critical Health okay somebody
else got that news part we're working on
getting it but critical Health follow us
on Facebook we appreciate you for
joining us here each and every day I
know some of them are diehards speaking
of Die Hard we have some some people
that come on each and every day Monday
through Friday 12 to 1 p.m Pacific time
and we're so glad you do because that
just proves that you value yourself
enough to show up and be a sponge so
that whenever you encounter somebody
that you love or somebody in your
community you are armed with information
that can help them also so be that
sponge soak it all up squeeze it out
plant seeds and folks if you have ever
thought about making a little bit of
income from home
look into our health coach program
you can become a distributor without
going through the health coach program
but if you want to become a distributor
an associate with youngevity and really
have it powerful that
program by The Institute of holistic
health you can find more information at
coachwith Becca or get back with the
person that shared this program with you
and ask if they know about the coaching
program
until next time everybody
bye for now
bye everybody